mysteriöse schiffswracks die in einer
wüste vor sich hin rosten
das war ökologischer selbstmord
betonblöcke die wie drachen szene aus
einem italienischen gebirgskamm wachsen
[Musik]
unheimlicher anblick mitten in dieser
wunderschönen berglandschaften
verlassene häuser die wie spuk schlösser
im wald stehen
wie ein dorf der verdammten man spürt
richtig dass da was passiert sein muss
und ein einstiges glanzstück der technik
das heute in einer einsamen bucht
verrottet
es ist so verwüstet das eigentlich nur
eine wirkliche katastrophe passiert sein
kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten ihrer zeit
mit das modernste regisseurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden die anlagen aufgegeben
manche sind heute lebensgefährlich
verseucht wer hat sie errichtet und wie
und warum wurden sie aufgegeben
[Applaus]
[Musik]
im herzen zentralasiens liegt die
ehemalige sowjet republik usbekistan
besuchern die den westen des landes
bereisen bietet sich ein gespenstisches
bild
[Musik]
in der weiten wüstenlandschaft nahe der
stadt molo obliegen schiffswracks
verstreut kleine fischerboote ebenso wie
mächtige kutter
willkommen am aralsee
aber wo ist das wasser
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein schiff in der wüste ist ein
seltsamer anblick man verbindet schiffe
ja automatisch mit wasser aber dort ist
einfach keins
eine armada rostiger pötte mitten in der
wüste ohne irgendein ufer in sicht
es sieht aus wie nach der apokalypse man
muss kein experte sein um zu sehen was
da etwas ganz gehörig schief gelaufen
ist
teile von mumok wirken wie eine
geisterstadt was ist hier passiert
der fisch auf dem statt schild gibt
einen hinweis wie es hier früher einmal
ausgesehen hat
anscheinend war die fischreiche einmal
sehr wichtig
schon seltsam denn man sieht nirgendwo
wasser das nächste gewässer ist
kilometerweit weg
[Applaus]
wo ist das ganze wasser hin und warum
haben die menschen minogue verlassen
[Musik]
die antwort auf dieses rätsel findet
sich mehr als 2000 kilometer
nordwestlich in moskau in den 1950 er
jahren gehört usbekistan zur sowjetunion
das sozialistische riesenreich erstreckt
sich damals vom baltikum bis zum pazifik
und umfasst den kaukasus sowie weite
teile zentralasiens
[Musik]
die macht hat generalsekretär josef
stalin in der das land auch durch den
zweiten weltkrieg geführt hat
die sowjetunion leidet schwer unter den
folgen des krieges und stalins
repressiver politik als der diktator
1953 stirbt hinterlässt er seinem
nachfolger nikita chruschtschow das land
in einem desolaten zustand
der neue generalsekretär versuchte es
mit wirtschaftsreformen allerdings in
alten strukturen
in der sowjetunion herrschte
planwirtschaft alle entscheidungen
wurden ganz oben getroffen da hieß es
dann genoss du baust weizen an und du
genosse baumwolle und du produzierst
stahl
die einzelnen bezirke kombinate und
arbeiter hatten kaum was zu sagen und
die machthaber dachten sie hätten das
wissen um alles zu entscheiden
republik müssen rohstoffe und
industriegüter an die zentralregierung
abliefern im gegenzug bekommen sie dann
lebensmittel und waren eines von moskau
kontrolliert
es gab keinen platz für experimente oder
abweichler sobald der befehl von oben
kam standen alle strom- und hatten sich
anzupassen
auch für minogue hat das zentralkomitee
seiner eigenen pläne
beim anblick dieser einöde fällt es
schwer sich das vorzustellen aber vor 60
jahren liegt das städtchen noch direkt
am ufer des aralsees
damals der viertgrößte see der erde
[Musik]
mehr als 30.000 menschen leben in den
kurort die meisten arbeiten als fischer
oder in der fischfabrik eine der größten
der sowjetunion auch almaz towa schiff
verdiente dort seinen lebensunterhalt
gab es mehr als 200 schiffe
über 100 kutter brachten den fisch in
die konservenfabrik
die 1200 arbeiter dort produzierten bis
zu zwölf millionen dosen fisch pro jahr
die fischerei blüte am aralsee denn es
ist einfach dort zu fischen das salzige
wasser ist ziemlich leicht und friert im
winter nicht zu man konnte also fast das
ganze jahr über fischen
der aralsee liefert rund ein sechstel
der gesamten sowjetischen
fischproduktion die fischerei gibt
zehntausenden lohn und brot
[Musik]
die usb kische fischproduktion wurde
damals zu 80 bis 90 prozent aus dem
aralsee gedeckt
es gab 34 fischarten im see 20 davon
waren wichtige speisefische für den
handel
neben der großen konservenfabrik gab es
zwölf fischfarmen und 65 locken jeder
hatte irgendwas mit der fischerei zu tun
[Musik]
aber 1990 ist schluss im fisch kombinat
morlok die gegend um die ehemalige
hafenstadt hat sich in eine wüste
verwandelt
wohin ist das ganze wasser verschwunden
die spur führt hinaus in der
zentralasiatischen steppe zu den
baumwollfeldern
wächst schon seit jahrhunderten der
aralsee region aber und das darlehen
wurde der anbau massiv angeschoben er
verkündete der ganzen welt dass die
sowjetunion der führende
baumwollproduzent werden würde
in diesem teil ist pakistans fallen im
schnitt nur zehn zentimeter regen pro
jahr ähnlich wie in der moral die wüste
oder einigen gebieten der sahara man
brauchte also künstliche bewässerung und
woher nahmen sie das wasser aus den
beiden flüssen die den aralsee speisten
staudämme und staubecken wurden angelegt
ein gigantisches bewässerungssystemen
stand mit einem kanalnetz von tausenden
kilometern ein typisches sowjet
megaprojekt
aber die pflanzen brauchen nicht nur
wasser damit sie auf dem kargen boden
gedeihen werden und mengen kunstdünger
und andere chemikalien eingesetzt
für baumwolle braucht man jede menge
dünger und pestizide vor allem da wo die
sowjets es an bauten sie versprühten das
zeug in massen es floss ab und verseucht
das grundwasser das bisschen wasser das
noch immer ankam war voller gift
der produktionsplan auf kosten des
aralsees geht dennoch auf
pakistan entwickelte sich zu einem der
wichtigsten baumwollproduzenten der
sowjetunion auch heute spielt es noch
eine wichtige rolle
den preis dafür zahlt das ökosystem
wenn man von dem wasser das den sie
speist vier fünftel abzweigt sind die
folgen dramatisch die lebensader ist
praktisch gekappt
[Musik]
das war ökologischer selbstmord denn
weil sie das wasser aus den flüssen um
leiteten floss nicht mehr genug in den
aralsee das ist eine trockene oft heiße
gegend meist scheint die sonne ohne dass
wasser aus seinen zuflüssen begann der
aralsee zu verdunsten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dann merkten die leute dass es immer
weniger wasser gab sie hatten nicht mal
genug für ihre gärten und höfe
um ihren lebensunterhalt weiter zu
verdienen ziehen die fischer von mumok
dem wasser hinterher aber schnell wird
klar dass das problem noch viel größer
ist die fische sterben
durch den wassersport zieht sich nicht
nur die uferlinie zurück das wasser wird
auch immer salziger früher waren es
knapp zehn gramm salz pro liter jetzt
sind es mancherorts mehr als 100 also
zehnmal mehr das verkraften die fische
nicht sie werden regelrecht vergiftet
der fischreiche süßwassersee verwandelte
sich in ein totes mehren
[Musik]
ende der 80er jahre verschwinden die
letzten einheimischen fischarten aus der
giftigen salzlake
innerhalb von vier jahrzehnten ist der
wasserspiegel um mehr als 20 meter
gefallen an manchen stellen hat sich die
uferlinie rund 150 kilometer
zurückgezogen
es ist erschreckend wie schnell das ging
dieses juwel der viertgrößte see der
erde ist zu einer kleinen seenkette
verkümmert der rest ist bloss noch wüste
der grund des sees ist trocken gefallen
dabei wurden hunderte millionen tonnen
staub und salz freigesetzt zusammen mit
dem pestizid resten im boden ergibt das
einen wahren giftcocktail
am ende brach alles zusammen
für die menschen am aralsee muss es
herzzerreißend gewesen sein ihre kultur
ihre lebensweise die sie
jahrhundertelang gepflegt hatten
vernichtet innerhalb weniger jahrzehnte
[Musik]
heute kosten die werks der fischkutter
am ehemaligen hafen von new york vor
sich in eine flotte von geisterschiff
erinnerungen an eine blühende
küstenstadt
von den einwohnern die geblieben sind
haben viele gesundheitliche schäden
aus dem aralsee ist eine wüste geworden
die arag um
das ist ein echtes lehrstück in sachen
umweltzerstörung es geht nicht nur um
ein schönes leben in einer idyllischen
umgebung auch entscheidende teile der
wirtschaft hängen von einem gesunden öko
system ab
dieser dramatische wandel zeigt uns wie
empfindlich unsere umwelt sein kann und
es ist eine mahnung wir dürfen nicht den
falschen schalter umlegen und diese
ökosysteme in die katastrophe steuern
[Applaus]
[Musik]
gut 50 kilometer südwestlich von berlin
liegt ein verlassener gebäude komplex
mitten im wald
[Musik]
wie ein dorf der verdammten
man spürt richtig dass da etwas passiert
ist
die baufälligen häuser verleihen dem ort
eine einzigartige und gruselige
atmosphäre
in einem der gebäude gibt es einen raum
mit einem wasserbecken in der mitte sehr
seltsam was war da los
man sieht sofort wie anspruchsvoll die
anlage gestaltet wurde mit seilen
terrassen und prachtvollen portalen fast
wie ein palast
[Musik]
auf dem knapp zwei quadratkilometer
großen gelände stehen rund 60
einzelgebäude welche düsteren
geheimnisse könnten sich hinter den
verfallenen mauern verbergen und was
verbindet diesen morbiden ort mit einem
der berüchtigsten verbrecher der
weltgeschichte
[Musik]
berlin an der schwelle des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts die industrielle revolution
hat die hauptstadt des deutschen
kaiserreichs in rasantem tempo verändert
in sachen technologie liegt die
spreemetropole auf dem spitzenplatz in
europa sogar grossbritannien das
mutterland der industriellen revolution
kann da nicht mithalten
die technischen hochschulen die
deutschland im lauf des 19 jahrhunderts
gegründet hat machen sich bezahlt
das land der dichter und denker setzt
auf neue brillante köpfe die ingenieure
die folge industrie und forschung blühen
und locken zahllose glücksritter an
zwischen 1871 und 1910 verdoppelt sich
die zahl der einwohner in kaiserreich in
berlin wächst sie um fast das dreifache
[Musik]
deutschland war im vergleich zu anderen
europäischen ländern ein nachzügler bei
der industriellen revolution aber das
machten die deutschen mehr als wett in
den 1800 90er jahren war der fortschritt
rasant fast schon chaotisch
fabriken schossen aus dem boden arme
schlucker zogen vom land in die große
stadt die leute wohnten
zusammengepfercht in engen mietskasernen
unter unmöglichen hygienischen
bedingungen und mit den menschenmassen
kam eine vielzahl von krankheiten
vor über 120 jahren verbreitet vor allem
eine solche in deutschland angst und
schrecken die tuberkulose auch
schwindsucht genannt
die krankheit wird durch
tröpfcheninfektion beim husten oder
niesen übertragen menschen die dicht
aufeinander hocken stecken sich sehr
leicht an
die hygiene war damals natürlich auch
nicht wie heute also man hat ja wenn es
überhaupt mit zahnbürste gab in einem
arbeiterhaus halt dann wurde die von
allen genutzt und sehr viele leute haben
ihre kinder unwissentlich mit
tuberkulose angesteckt
über ein jahrhundert lang ist
tuberkulose in manchen gegenden die
todesursache nummer eins nicht nur in
deutschland
ein medikament dagegen gibt es noch
nicht rund 80 prozent der erkrankten
sterben
gegen tuberkulose gab es kein richtiges
heilmittel aber man versuchte eine
heilsame umgebung für die patienten zu
schaffen die idee war wenn es eine
lungenkrankheit ist hat es doch etwas
mit luft zu tun die leute sollten also
raus aus der stadt an die frische
trockene luft
es war üblich reiche patienten in die
berge zu schicken in idyllische kurorte
aber die meisten tuberkulose opfer
hatten kein geld sie konnten sich das
nicht leisten
für die tb krankenkassen in den armen
häusern berlins muss ein neues konzept
her das lungen sanatorium beelitz
heilstätten
in der guten luft vor den toren der
reichshauptstadt sollen die
schwindsüchtigen wieder zu kräften
kommen
hinter dem sanatorium steckte die
landesversicherungsanstalt berlin sie
wollte eine klinik für arbeiter
errichten die sonst kaum chancen auf
eine behandlung hatten
aber würden die patienten aus den
berliner elendsvierteln hier tatsächlich
gelesen
[Musik]
viele dieser menschen lebten auf engstem
raum die meisten waren arme
fabrikarbeiter vielleicht gab es auch zu
hause niemanden der sich um sie kümmern
konnte selbst wenn die heilungschancen
nicht die besten waren in so einem
gepflegten an lesen sein zu dürfen muss
für sie ein segen gewesen sein
zwischen 1898 und
1902 entstehen die ersten arbeiter
lungenheilstätte auf dem gelände die
kunstvollen verzierungen an den fassaden
und die hohen lichten räume stehen im
krassen gegensatz zum dunklen mief der
mietskasernen
die beelitzer heilstätten sind nicht
irgendein krankenhaus mit
operationssälen langen fluren auf den
stationen normalen wenden und
lüftungssystemen hier hat man versucht
licht und luft ins haus zu bringen und
eine atmosphäre zu schaffen in der sich
die menschen wohlfühlen
[Musik]
es wirkt wie ein luxus ressort eine
idyllische kleinstadt auf dem land
ich finde es toll mit welchem respekt
man den kranken menschen begegnete die
eigentlich gar kein geld für so etwas
hatten
die obrigkeit hat allerdings auch eine
gründe ihre untertanen fit zu machen
der kaiser hatte einfach angst vor der
wetten unfähigkeit von der unfähigkeit
des landes und die wirtschaft die hat
ihre billigen arbeitskräfte verloren und
das war der grund dieser heilstätten
outen
schon kurz nach der eröffnung der
heimstätten wird die anlage erweitert
mit insgesamt 1200 betten gehört beelitz
heilstätten damals zu den größten
sanatorien der welt
[Musik]
nach dem ausbruch des ersten weltkriegs
haben die schwindsüchtigen zivilisten
allerdings das nachsehen
die anlage wird vom roten kreuz als
lazarett gebraucht
mehr als 1500 betten stehen bereit um
verwundete soldaten aufzunehmen unter
ihnen ist auch ein junger gefreiter der
als kriegsverbrecher und völkermörder in
die geschichte eingehen wird adolf
hitler
hitler war en der 1916 für zwei monate
zur behandlung in beelitz eine granate
hatte ihn am linken bein verletzt
1920 zwei jahre nach ende des ersten
weltkriegs aus dem lazarett beelitz
heilstätten wird wieder ein sanatorium
mehr als zwei jahrzehnte lang werden
hier weiter schwindsüchtige gepflegt
während mediziner fieberhaft an einem
medikament gegen die tödliche krankheit
forschen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
tuberkulose blieb ein ernstzunehmendes
problem in den industrieländern bis
gegen ende des zweiten weltkriegs ein
antibiotikum gefunden wurde streptomycin
stellte sich als ziemlich wirksam heraus
ab den 50er jahren kommen weitere
tuberkulose mittel auf dem markt das
risiko an der solche zu sterben sind
lungen kuren wie in beelitz verlieren an
bedeutung
[Musik]
aber die heilstätten stehen noch lange
nicht vor dem aus nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg übernimmt die sowjetische
armee das gelände
[Musik]
das soll jetzt haben die beelitzer
heilstätten
als größtes militärhospital außerhalb
der eigenen landesgrenzen
91 begann langsam der abzug der
sowjetischen truppen und 94 war dann das
gelände wieder näher
[Musik]
heute sind die einst prachtvollen klinik
ordnung verfallen dass hier ein kampf
gegen die schwindsucht geführt wurde
wirkt wie eine fußnote der geschichte
aber die krankheit ist längst nicht
besiegt
[Musik]
seit den 80er jahren treten antibiotika
resistente bakterienstämme auf
laut der whu ist tuberkulose immer noch
die tödlichste infektionskrankheit der
welt
das ausmaß der solche in der ersten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhundert zwei
enorm die folgen trafen weite teile
europas oder wie viele zu erinnern uns
daran und da es heute wieder steigende
infektionszahlen gibt ist es vielleicht
eine gute meinung wie gefährlich diese
krankheit ist
[Musik]
von der luft kurklinik in die luftigen
höhen der italienischen alpen
[Musik]
rund 2000 meter über dem meeresspiegel
ragen seltsame spitzen wie drachen zähne
aus dem schnee
[Musik]
diese seltsamen pyramiden ähnlichen
dinger haben was von moderner kunst
hunderte beton szene die aus der alten
landschaft emporragen sind ein irrer
anblick
man weiß echt nicht was das sein soll
vom betonsockel bis zur stahlspitze sind
die bizarren poller bis zu einem meter
hoch
sie ziehen sich wie ein riesiger
nietengürtel hunderte meter über die
alpine hochebene aber warum wurden sie
in dieser einöde aufgestellt
wo die dinger stehen es doch echt schräg
direkt am gipfel da gehören sie einfach
nicht hin
es sieht fast mittelalterlich aus fast
wie aus game of thrones ein sehr
unheimlicher ort mitten in dieser
wunderschönen berglandschaft
etwas weiter unten im tal gibt es an den
hinweis was das für ein bollwerk sein
könnte
die suche nach dem geheimnis der drachen
szene führt ins innere des berges
hinter einer geheimtür erstreckt sich
ein weitverzweigtes tunnelsystem
die tür zu diesem labyrinth ist eine
felsen attrappe die direkt in den hang
hinein gebaut wurde
auf den ersten blick wirkt sie
unglaublich massiv und sie passt sich
perfekt in die umgebung ein
da hat sich jemand nicht mühe gegeben
aber wozu was soll diese bizarre anlage
hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die antwort führt zurück in die 1930 er
jahre in europa herrscht ein wackliger
frieden
die niederlage im ersten weltkrieg und
den friedensvertrag von versailles
empfinden viele deutsche immer noch als
schwach sie setzen auf adolf hitler und
seine nazis um das vaterland zu retten
in italien herrscht der faschist benito
mussolini
seit den grausamen kämpfen mit millionen
toten sind gerade mal 15 jahre vergangen
und schon droht europa ein neuer krieg
die wichtigsten mächte auf dem kontinent
beginnen ihre grenzen massiv zu
verstärken
in frankreich gab es all diese anlagen
die zur vermeintlich unbezwingbaren
maginot-linie gehörten die deutschen
warten unterdessen ihre eigene version
den west weist in front
solche verteidigungsanlagen fanden sich
in ganz europa eine vernünftige
vorsichtsmaßnahme denn es gab ja eine
echte bedrohung
[Musik]
in italien lässt mussolini seit ende der
20er jahre an einer geheimen
schutzanlage in den alpen bauen der
sogenannte valo alpino sollen sich über
1600 kilometer quer durch das
hochgebirge ziehen
[Musik]
von ventimiglia an der westküste bis
nach wie ohne im osten
[Musik]
der abschnitt in südtirol trägt den
deutschen namen altenwall
auf dem hochplateau psalm ortsnahe dem
reschenpass werden ab 1938 die bizarren
der tanzszene sowie bunker und waffen
stellungen errichtet aber der
verteidigungswall ist in erster linie
nicht so abwehr des kriegsgegners
gedacht mussolini will sich vor seinem
engsten verbündeten schützen adolf
hitler der hat kurz zuvor österreich
annektiert
[Musik]
mussolini traute hitler nicht er wusste
dass sich die grenzen des deutschen
reiches ausdehnen sollte und mit
österreich hatte er bestimmt auch etwas
vor für die italiener war das ein
problem denn sie hatten südtirol 1918
besetzt
er vermutete dass er das gebiet
zurückfordern und italien angreifen
wollte
panzer sind seit den ersten weltkrieg zu
einer der schlagkräftigsten waffen im
kampf geworden und die nazis haben ihre
wehrmacht seit 1935 massiv aufgerüstet
wie sollte italien seine alten grenze
gegen diese stahl monster schützen
zu den drängendsten für die drachen
zähler oder dirty drago wurden holz
pfähle in den boden gerammt mit beton
ummantelt und das ganze mit einer
stahlspitze gekrönt diese sperre war für
panzerfahrzeuge unüberwindlich
große truppenverbände während
stattdessen umgeleitet worden direkt in
eine kampfzone wo man sie leicht
ausschalten konnte
[Musik]
zur italienischen verteidigungslinie
gehört auch ein netzwerk von bunkern und
waffen stellungen die sperren erstrecken
sich über mehrere staffeln bis zu 70
kilometer ins landesinnere
mit mehreren sperren hintereinander kann
man eine angriffswelle den schwung
nehmen das macht es einfacher sie
zurückzuschlagen
es ist eine ganze reihe von
befestigungsanlagen der feindliche
vormarsch wird gestoppt und verzögert
zeit die man zum gegenangriff nutzen
kann
manche eingänge zur italienischen
alpenfestung sind gut getarnt
[Musik]
hinter dieser felsen etappe liegt bunker
nummer 20
ludwig schöpf führt manchmal touristen
in das labyrinth aus geheim gängen und
ehemaligen waffen kamen
[Musik]
der pensionierte lehrer und fotograf
erklärt wie gefährlich der dienst damals
war
[Musik]
das ist das maschinengewehr nest von
bunker nummer 20
hier standen drei soldaten
liegt außerhalb des berges hier fängt
der fels an das alles sagt nach draußen
die soldaten wussten dass es sie bei
einem angriff als erstes erwischen würde
da
die künstliche filz vertreibung soll den
soldaten schutz und die möglichkeit für
einen überraschungsangriff bieten
[Musik]
sie haben den bunker von außen mit fels
attrappen getarnt erst wenn man direkt
vor der wand steht merkt man dass das
nicht echt ist aber dann ist das feuer
schon eröffnet
aber wie sicher waren die bunker selbst
die betonwände waren zum teil knapp vier
meter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sie verbauten den beton in und um das
gestein herum sie nutzen also die felsen
auf beiden seiten des passes als
natürliche barriere und erweiterten sie
durch bollwerke von menschenhand
mussolini fürchtet eine einmarsch der
deutschen auch weil er weiß dass es in
südtirol eine starke heim ins reich
bewegung gibt hitler hat mussolini
eigentlich zugesagt die grenze zu
respektieren
es hätte sein können dass die deutschen
truppen losschicken am ende sind sie
auch über die alten grenze einmarschiert
kam der alpen war jemals zum einsatz
die verteidigungslinien wurden nie
benutzt nach dem sturz mussolinis gaben
die italiener auf wo die deutschen
marschierten in norditalien ein
[Musik]
die alpen ball war über weite strecken
nur spärlich mit truppen besetzt und das
waren grenzschützer keine frontsoldaten
es war also keine richtige
verteidigungslinie
die soldaten gaben einfach auf die
befestigungsanlage war zwar sehr
durchdacht aber letztendlich war sie
nutzlos
nach ihrem einmarsch nutzen die
deutschen die anlage selbst zur abwehr
der alliierten die von süden durch
italien richtung dran zu ziehen
aber auch hier kommt es nicht zu
kampfhandlungen
[Musik]
heute dienen die rostigen spitzen der
drachen szene als denkmal für ein
dunkles kapitel der europäischen
geschichte
[Musik]
sich die bizarren gebilde heute
anzuschauen ist wie ein trip in die
vergangenheit
es wäre auch zu teuer sie zu entfernen
deswegen sollte man sie einfach als
mahnmal akzeptieren als seltsames
bollwerk mitten in den alpen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ostküste kanadas
aus eiskalten fluten ragen die rostigen
überreste eines schiffs rumpfes gerade
knapp über die wasserlinie
[Musik]
es hat was von einem monster aus der
tiefsee
aber warum wird es langsam vom meer
verschlungen
das wrack liegt in einer einsamen bucht
vor der küste neufundlands
dieses teils versunkene grippe hat etwas
mysteriöses und durch die idyllische
gegend in der es liegt wird das noch
verstärkt
es sieht aus wie ein sandwich aus
schrott und rostigem stahl bei dem ein
teil kann man noch reste eines modernen
kutters erkennen aber was daneben
vertäut ist erinnert eher an eine
explodierte fabrik das gehörte einfach
nicht hin
vom ufer aus kann man nur noch ein paar
teile sehen der rest des wracks liegt
unter wasser
[Musik]
es ist so heftig zerstört dass man sich
als grund nur eine größere katastrophe
vorstellen kann
dies sind die überreste des calypso
einst eines der stolzesten schiffe der
britischen marine nun verrottet es in
der sogenannten bernd b nördlich der
stadt louis port
das schicksal der calypso hängt eng mit
ihrer ehemaligen bestimmung zusammen
ende des 19 jahrhunderts ist
großbritannien eine führende weltmacht
in seiner blütezeit herrscht das empire
über ein viertel der globalen landmasse
rund 450 millionen menschen unterstehen
der britischen krone in den helfen
herrscht hochkonjunktur
waren aus aller welt werden verschifft
um die industrielle revolution in
schwung zu halten
[Musik]
großbritannien die kleine insel im
nordatlantik ist überaus reich und
mächtig und das liegt zum großen teil an
seiner flotte
[Musik]
in den 1800 70er jahren ist
großbritannien die absolute super macht
niemand hat eine vergleichbare marine
niemand herrscht so weltumspannend
und ganz egal welche widrigkeiten es
gibt die royal navy sorgt dafür dass
niemand dem handel zwischen
großbritannien und seinen kolonien in
die quere kommt
[Musik]
die ages calypso war für den kampf gegen
verfeindete europäische staaten und
piraten gedacht die korvette fuhr mit
einer kombination aus segeln und dann
sie hatte dampfkessel konnte aber auch
die segel setzen dadurch konnte die
calypso lange patrouillenfahrten machen
und sich dabei vom wind tragen lassen
das schiff kommt es so auch in die
gewässer weit abgelegene kolonien
vordringen wo es vielleicht probleme mit
dem brennstoff nachschub gab
die ausstattung machte den kreuzer
zuverlässiger und er konnte besser seine
pflicht erfüllen
ausdauer und robustheit waren die
größten stärken der calypso das
verdankte sie unter anderem ihrer
besonderen rumpf konstruktion
der rumpf ist aus verschiedenen
materialien gefertigt ein eisen grippe
mit stahlplatten ziemlich modern aber
darauf liegt holz die planken ragen
heute noch aus dem wasser warum
verkleidet man ein stahl schiff mit holz
stahl allein kann ein schiff nicht vor
bio fouling schützen so nennt man den
bewuchs mit organismen wie seepocken
oder algen das kann den rumpf und den
antrieb beschädigen
eine kupfer schicht soll den bewuchs
verhindern
man kann das kupfer aber nicht direkt
auf den stahl packen weil sonst ein
galvanischer strom entsteht durch den
kontakt der beiden metalle würde der
ganze rumpf korrodieren deswegen baut
man holz über den stahlrumpf und legt
dann zum schluss die kupfer schicht
darüber
im juni
1883 läuft die calypso in der englischen
chattem werft mit großem tamtam vom
stapel sie ist eines der letzten segel
dampfschiffe die das britische empire
bauen lässt
sie war kein altmodisches schlachtschiff
für ihre größe hatte sie ganz schön bunt
was hat der stolzen korvette das genick
gebrochen
barnes piraten oder feindliche schiffe
weder noch
letztendlich war das design ihr
verderben
sobald die royal navy ein schiff bauen
ließ zogen die französische und die
deutsche marine nach und übertrumpften
ist
[Musik]
in den 1800 70er jahren waren schiffe
wie die calypso für kurze zeit äußerst
schlagkräftig aber zehn jahre später
waren sie schon total veraltet
1902 wird die calypso über den atlantik
geschickt sie soll als training schiff
für die rolle wie in neufundland dienen
1922 wird sie ausgemustert und verkauft
ein paar jahrzehnte später kommt das
endgültige aus
[Musik]
1968 wurde das schiff aufgegeben und in
eine kleine bucht in der nähe von ambri
geschleppt dort wurde es dann bis zur
wasserlinie niedergebrannt
heute ist das wrack eine
touristenattraktion in neufundland
ein schiff wie die calypso ist für mich
ein denkmal es erinnert an all die
menschen die hart arbeiten um etwas
großartiges zu bauen
[Musik]
ingenieurs und bauprojekte den verfall
preisgegeben sie erzählen von krieg und
krisen aber auch vom erfindergeist und
fortschritt von allen wozu menschen
fähig sind
[Musik]